make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to another episode of
beyond omega-level you guys loved the
video Anshu McGrath so let me know if
you guys want me to cover like any
stories belonging to Shu McGrath right I
didn't realize you guys are gonna love
it that much I was like alright we'll
make a video bathroom Agora acid giant
tentacle monster with one eye and then
we'll see you it's like holy now this
videos blowing up
that's usually the best indicator of
what you guys enjoy like that's usually
the test that I use to figure out what
it is that you guys like right because
it's just so many people talking if I
say hey guys do you want this there's
just so many people seeing things so the
easiest way to determine what you guys
do and do not like is what you guys
watch right because people don't watch
videos they don't like the only
exception that I had with that if it's
just something that I really want to
cover and I don't really care how well
it does then I'll just do stuff like
transformers right I never really expect
transformers to blow up on my channel
but I just like covering because it's
just cool but yeah so you guys like a
lot of you guys watch you McGrath a lot
of you guys really seem to love
Schumacher ass so let me know if you
want me to make it like a video you know
like you like either an explained video
or like some videos on unlike stories
about sue McGrath like he shows up and
does some things let me know but in this
video we are focusing on the son of
Franklin Richards hyper storm so hyper
storm was created by Tom DeFalco and
Paul Ryan and first appeared in
Fantastic Four number 406 and 1995 and
to understand the origin of Jonathan
Reed Richards we first have to talk
about the classic x-men story Days of
Future past
so Days of Future past is one of the
most iconic x-men stories ever and it
was written by really the most iconic
x-men writer of all time of course I'm
talking about Chris Claremont and it was
drawn by John Byrne and uncanny x-men
issues 141 and 142 in 1981 I don't mean
to make that sound like an aside right
like it was written by Chris Claremont
and drawn by John Byrne like I don't
mean to make it seem that way but the
storyline actually takes place in an
alternate future so not in the main
Marvel continuity and in this continuity
which is designated earth 811 mutants
are the victims of extreme persecution
and they're all either killed by the
signals or imprisonment and all this
comes in response to the assassination
of Robert Kelley more McTaggart in
Charles Xavier
all that resolves by Rachel summers
sending Kitty Prydz consciousness back
into her younger self to warn the x-men
to stop the assassination from coming
about and so in an offshoot of that
universe dubbed earth 967 we see Rachel
summers who's the daughter of Scott
Summers in Jean Grey and Franklin
Richards the son of Reed and Susan storm
are basically married and they have a
son named Jonathan now predictably since
both of his parents are omega-level
mutant Jonathan is the most powerful
being in his reality but unlike his
parents Jonathan decides to use his
powers to conquer the entire universe
and serving as a cruel dictator of all
the worlds that he's conquered now once
hyper storm learns of the Fantastic Four
he begins hatching a plan to terrorize
them now the first phase of his plan was
to pull the villain tomorrow man who had
the ability to time travel out of the
timestream and send him back in time to
battle the Fantastic Four and then
captures both Reed Richards and dr. doom
trapping Reed in a pocket dimension and
throwing dr. doom in jail now believing
mr. fantastic to be dead if the
Fantastic Four are devastated but they
are able to trace the movements of
tomorrow man back to hyper storms
reality and they travel there to find
out what in the heck is going on but he
is summarily able to defeat them all now
it isn't until Reed is able to wake up
Galactus that hyper storm was able to be
defeated as Galactus recognized hyper
storm as a nearly limitless source of
power and tried to consume him now after
a battle between hyper storm and
Galactus they're both involuntarily
transported back to the dimensional void
that it housed Galactus prior to his
awakening where Reed predicts that
they'll be locked in an eternal struggle
of course we know that didn't actually
happen because we've seen Galactus many
times since then while hyper storm has
not appeared since at least to my
knowledge and so as to what hyper storms
powers actually are he describes himself
as wielding the supreme power which
allows him to manipulate the major
forces of the universe electromagnetism
gravity and strong and weak nuclear
forces he also states that these forces
come from hyperspace a limited source of
energy which means that his abilities
are basically infinite Hyper's form is
able to use the supreme power to perform
a variety of feat due to the fact that
controlling all the fundamental forces
of the universe allows him to manipulate
matter and energy which makes him
practically omnipotent now we have seen
him use his abilities in a variety of
ways including increasing its physical
strength to a level far beyond the thing
and according to Reed Richards at least
equal to the combined strength of the
thing and named work hyper storm also
has an
same level of durability most notably
standing up to the full brunt of the
Nova flame from the human torch without
showing any indication that he felt any
kind of pain he's also not overly
affected by Susan storms forcefield
vibrations which she reveals are also
rooted in the hyperspace dimension so
because hyper storm is able to control
all the forces from that hyper space
he's even able to endure them being used
against him with only minor discomfort
he's also used energy manipulation to
produce energy blasts capable of taking
out Susan storm thing name war and dr.
Doom's son Christophe Renard all in one
shot which is quite an impressive feat
given the durability of those characters
and the fact that Susan storm was able
to create force fields that could hold
off the Celestials in addition to his
energy manipulation hyper storm is an
extremely capable telekinetic and his
telekinesis has often been used in ways
that are pretty close to reality warping
for example he was able to move the air
molecules around him fast enough to
create a tornado that put out the human
torch's flame which has the same amount
of energy as an exploding star when
battling named war hyper storm creates a
tree that's able to siphon off all of
the name war's moisture which
effectively means that he's altering
name or cellular makeup is also worth
pointing out that the amount of moisture
that exists within Namor is extremely
high due to his Atlantean physiology and
as a result the tree absorbs so much
moisture that the human torch is almost
unable to destroy it with his flame we
confronted by Ben Grimm
Piper Storm is able to hold him in place
and heal extensive damage that had been
done to his face now it's unclear by
what mechanism he's able to do this
whether it's just by moving the
molecules around or whether he does
possess some kind of reality warping
abilities which wouldn't make sense
given his lineage since Franklin
Richards is a universal constant reality
warper but at any rate it shows us that
hyper storm is basically able to do
anything his mind can conceive of now
additionally hyper storm possesses
several other powers including
invisibility teleportation through
hyperspace and a regenerative healing
factor
he's also displayed a wide array of
telepathic abilities including the
ability to read and control the minds of
others cause hallucinations cloak his
presence from others and limited astral
projection he also possesses a
genius-level intellect and is put it to
use inventing extremely advanced
technologies such as a time machine a
device called a brain disarray tur which
disrupts the neural pathways of whoever
it's used on and nearly indestructible
robots known as Destructoid's and so
although hyper storm has only made
handful of appearances and was only
around for one singular story arc but we
do know about him allows us to put him
firmly in the beyond Omega level
category he possesses the attributes of
both of his parents the psychic
abilities of Rachel summers and the
reality warping abilities of Franklin
Richards as well as his grandfather
supreme intelligence he's able to
harness the fundamental forces of the
universe is able to manipulate matter on
a molecular level and was able to
conquer every inhabited world in his
universe and destroy the Fantastic Four
on every known plane of reality except
of course the Fantastic Four from
earth-616 and since we know the lacas is
definitely beyond Omega level in hyper
storm was thought to be able to be
powerful enough to battle him for all of
eternity or at least until another rider
wanted to use Galactus we can basically
say that he's at this same level as well
what would that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explained to
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Laughter]